we are so excited today because we're
revealing the amazing kitchen renovation
that we created for our friend and drew
gooder nurse and mother victoria jose
and after teaming up with this insanely
talented team to design and demo and do
all that it takes to create
a dream kitchen i'm talking every nook
and cranny was considered thought about
and executed all right
and i'm there to welcome victoria home
take a look
[Music]
hey victoria
how you doing
oh i'm here baby i am here
oh victoria i am so happy to see you in
person
we've been thinking about you so much
everybody has been a huge army of people
but
a lot of the design elements you know i
hope that you like and if you don't well
i might be responsible i would love it
so excited all right
[Music]
welcome home oh thank you
[Music]
what look at the pictures
we descended yesterday yes your family
is up on the wall
my dining table
i love it on the dining table got me
brand new dining tables i know how
important this table is it's the
centerpiece of you and your family thank
you
do you recognize this space
wow
because we took down a hoverboard yes
there was a wall here that was like a
cabinet or some kind of structure in
this middle oh victoria you had a
refrigerator in front of one of the
windows right there
i
did not think
that we were going to get this much
light into the room and that's one of
the things i'm most proud of
i brought all of our beautiful
kitchenware this is our toaster our air
fryers which are all the rage wow
where i think we need to go in the
kitchen is to stop doing too many
buttons and screens
let's let dried pasta stick out let's
let cookbooks and wooden pieces be the
centerpiece i love the colors i love the
browns and the grease that's my colors i
just thought let's go black countertops
yes stone tech fabrication was the
supplier that we used to build the
kitchen of our dreams this is beautiful
and a black sink wow so that it feels so
huge i liked the black trim on this
which is this great rubber and you've
got a goose neck i love a goose neck
new cabinet doors made these gorgeous
cabinets the windows had to be raised
because they were lower than a standard
countertop
do you want to know what my favorite
detail is in this kitchen
it's this tile this is tile
but it looks like wood and it's like
wood this is gorgeous i'm so excited
i would like to thank lg for getting us
one of their infamous
insta-view refrigerators
one detail of this fridge that i really
love is that
double tap you see a light you can also
press this button
and just get straight to your condiments
or juices or sort of quick pulls which
is actually energy saving and really
convenient
[Music]
tyson foods is supplying you with a year
of food just to have and enjoy and share
with your family and the holidays are
coming up
food uh-huh
my god
oh my god thank you
thank you thank you so much i just have
to tell you that being with you
you make people feel so loved and
appreciated and that must be such a
benefit to your family they're so lucky
thank and you take care of so many
people
and maybe this space can make you able
to help people but also give you
something back to refill your batteries
and take care of everybody else this is
more than a dream come true
we are a huge thanks to our friends at
article
for helping furnish victoria's gorgeous
space they did everything i was able to
pull every piece from them love them and
victoria is here along with her husband
abraham
and her daughters elizabeth and
albertina and her son abraham jr
[Applause]
i am blessed and highly favored thank
you so much thank you so much i'm so
grateful
i loved getting to do this project with
you so much you are so deserving you're
such a good person and you all love to
spend so much time together as a family
and you deserve light and a beautiful
space i know how much that kitchen table
gets tush time you spend all that time
in there i enjoy every moment of it
trust me well i know
[Music]
oh my god i'm so happy okay so you know
at the end of the day
whatever we do it it only matters if you
like it we love it we love it love it we
love it
[Music]
victoria i have another surprise for you
our friends at bp
not only did bp help fund this project
but they also want to give you a
thousand dollar gas gift card that you
can use
[Applause]
thank you
for giving back to your community i want
to say a personal thank you to them for
enabling us to do this um
i love you guys
[Music]
you